Chào ngày 2,5 tháng 2, thủ đứng phạm mình chính đã có cuộc liền đam với tân thủ đứng thay lan.
Anoting Chan Ví Đà Cún, tủ đứng trên trọng chuyển lời tham hỏi và lời chức xức quẻ của lãnh đạo Việt Nam
ở nhà buồn và hoàn hậu thay lan.
Chúng mình ở ăn ngủ tiêm Chan Ví Đà Cún, được nhà buồn phê chận làm tủ đứng thay lan.
Dính đường chính vụ và nhân dần thay lan sẽ tiếp tục ra những đừng nhiều thành tử to lớn hơn nữa, trong công cuộc sư dức và phát triển đứng nước.
Hủ đứng khẳng định Việt Nam có chọng và mong muốn đưa con này đối tác chính được quan viện Việt Nam thay lan.
Phát triển người cả mạnh mẽ, tính cậy và thực chất.
Cám ơn thủ đứng phạm mình chính, thủ tướng Anoting Chan Ví Đà Cún, nhấn mạnh.
Việt Nam là lãnh diền gần cuối đã đối tác quan chọng của thay lan.
Hủ đứng.
Khẳng định sẵn sẵn hợp tác với tủ đứng chính vụ Việt Nam.
Nhắm tăng cường hợp tác quan viện với hành lực, bils íc của nhé dần hành lực.
Đi hoa bình ổn lịch của bực.
Hành lãnh đạo đến rất kháo hành lực.
Nâng cấp lên quan hệ đối tác chính lực quan viện.
Đó tháng 5 bữa qua.
Nhất chỉ đến giá, hợp tác cứ hành lực, đăng phát triển mạnh mẽ, tìu qua, chỉ cần được.
Chúng đó hành lần tiếp tục giữ bị chí đối tác thương mạnh lớn nhất.
Và là nhà đục tư lức hói lớn tinh 2 của Việt Nam, trong ạ sẻ.
Tụi đứng phạm mình chính khẳng định sẽ tiếp tục tạo thật lợi cho các dân nghiệp thay lan.
Cứ rất nhiều quả tại Việt Nam.
Mong muốn hài bình hợp tác chất chế.
Thúc bài kết nối rau thông vận tại trong khu bực.
Tăng cường hợp tác ăn mình, gần hóa, sấu thụ đạo tạo.
Rau lương dân dân.
Tạo thân lợi và phát mùi vai cho cầu mối hú nghỉ.
Dưới dân dần thánh lực.
Húng tưởng thay lan nhất chi với thủ tượng phạm mình chính.
Bây giờ, cân thiết khó hợp chân chế, bình lấu sướng được kinh gạc thương mạnh 2 chiều.
Bà thay mấy năm tìm đối là Mỹ, mối năm.
Tăng cường gắn kinh hành nền kinh tế, thông vòi chình thay hợp quá chính được.
Bà kết nối.
Nhân dịp này tụt tưởng anoting chân vì đật quân.
Trân trọng mời thủ tưởng phạm mình chính thăm thái lan.
Bây giờ hội nghi cấp cao, mấy con lan thường và cuối năm nay.
Mong sớm được gặp và cho đổi chức tiếp, nhân dịp hải thủ tưởng.
Cùng thăm dự hội nghi đáp phương.
Nhưng hội nghi cấp cao asa trong thời gian tới.